اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي على مخيم جنين
والصحه العالميه تحذر من غياب ممر امن
للمساعدات الانسانيه
وحماس تتبنى عمليه تل ابيب وتقول ان
منفذها هو احد عناصرها ووزير الامن
الاسرائيلي يشدد على اهميه حمل السلاح
بوتن يتوعد بمواجهه محاولات تشكيل دوله
مناوئه على حدود روسيا وقلق غربي من بطء
الهجوم الاوكراني
معارك عنيفه في محيط سلاح المهندسين في ام
درمان بالخرطوم وانباء عن تقدم للجيش
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
تزدحم سماء مخيم جنين بطائرات الاستطلاع
لليوم الثاني من العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه على المخيم وسط استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي على اهداف داخله
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قال ان عمليه جنين
مستمره حتى تدمير البنيه التحتيه للارهاب
حسب تعبيره فيما نقلت القناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه عن مصادر رفيعه المستوى ان
حكومه نتنياهو وافقت على تمديد الهجوم على
جنين لوقت قصير بطلب من قاده الجيش والامن
الداخلي
وقالت هذه المصادر ان قاده الجيش واجهزه
الامن الداخلي اكدوا لنتنياهو ان اهداف
العمليه لم تتحقق بعد وان هناك ضروره
للحفاظ على زخمها مضيفه ان الغرض من ابقاء
القوات هناك هو مسح مواقع لما وصفته
بالارهاب حسب ما قال قاده الجيش
مستشفى المستشفى الكريم
سبب الاضراب انه اللي بصير في جنين
بيقبلوه لا قريب ولا قريب
[موسيقى]
من مخيم جنين ينضم الي مراسل العربيه خالد
قاسم خالد اهلا وسهلا بك خالد جديد المشهد
الميداني من جنين في هذه الاوقات وهل
المخيم يتهيا للاسوء في الساعات المقبله
خالد
والله طالب كل الاحتمالات مفتوحه داخل
مخيم جنين في هذه الاثناء وقع انفجار على
اطراف مخيم جنين سحب الدخان الابيض تتصاعد
من مكان
الانفجار حركه نشطه للمركبات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه تجوب
شوارع وازقه مخيم جنين ترافقها الجرافات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي تستهدف من بين
ما تستهدف تستهدف البنيه
التحتيه في المخيم كتدمير شبكات المياه
والكهرباء وقطع الانترنت ربما تستمع معي
طالب اصوات سيارات الاسعاف التي تحاول
الدخول الى داخل المخيم يبدو ان هناك
اصابات داخل المخيم تحاول مركبات الاسعاف
الوصول الى هذه الاصابات
واخلائها رغ الصعوبه التي تواجهها الاطقم
الطبيه في الدخول الى المخيم بسبب اما
اعاقه المركبات العسكريه الاسرائيليه حريه
حركه هذه المركبات الطبيه او لان
الطرقات قامت بتجريفها الجرافات
الاسرائيليه فبات من المستحيل على مركبات
الاسعاف
استخدامها او لكثافه اطلاق النار والتبادل
الاطلاق النار في الاماكن
داخل مخيم جنين او في وسط مخيم هنا هنا
خالد لو
الاسرائيلي
من قبل مقاتلي الفصائل في المخيم على
الاقل وفق مدى الرؤيه المتوفر لديك من حيث
انت متواجد وكذلك يعني لو فينا نتحدث ايضا
عن اخر اخبار النزوح
نعم وفق مدى الرؤيه ووفق مدى السماء ايضا
هناك تبادل لاطلاق النار بين الحين والاخر
عندما تمر الدوريات العسكريه في بعض
الاماكن يتم امطارها بصاليات من الرصاص من
قبل مسلحين فلسطينيين هنا ما تشاهده في
الصوره هي اشعال اطارات حيث تدور مواجهات
في هذه المنطقه وهي على المدخل الشرقي
لمخيم زينين تدور مواجهات مع القوات
الاسرائيليه التي تطلق قنابل الغاز
الرصاص المطاطي باتجاه
المتظاهرين يبدو ان هناك في هناك اصابات
وايضا هناك
دوريات عسكريه اسرائيليه تجوب شوارع
المخيم
هذه ناقلات جند ودوريات عسكريه
ادخل الى مخيم جنين من سؤال فقط لانه بعض
بعض وسائل الاعلام نقلت انه لدى المقاتلين
داخل المخيم اسلحه مضاده للاليات
والمدرعات هل لاحظت ان المقاتلين داخل
المخيم استخدموا مثل هكذا اسلحه املا هذا
الكلام غير صحيح يعني
الاشتباكات تتم من الجانب المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين باسلحه رشاشه وربما فرديه لا
اكثر ولا اقل هي فقط هي فقط اسلحه رشاشه
فرديه
وتفجير عبوات ناسفه محليات الصنع يتم
تصنيعها هنا في مخيم جنين وبحسب ادعاء
الجيش الاسرائيلي فانه قام بتدمير اكثر من
معملين لتصنيع المتفجرات داخل
المخيم اضافه الى تدمير بئ كانت تخزن به
الذخيره والاسلحه والمواد
المتفجره اما اطلاق صواريخ مضاده للدروع
ولم ننقل
لا من شهادات العيان ولا من الناطقين باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يتحدثوا عن هذا
الموضوع نهائي لنعود اليك بطبيعه الحال في
سياق متابعه مجريات ما يجري في مخيم جنين
من مخيم جنين مراسل العربيه خالد قاسم
شكرا جزيلا لك خالد على كل هذه المتابعه
اما في تل ابيب فقد اصيب عشره اسرائيليين
بينهم ثلاث حالات خطره ومتوسطه في حادث
قالت اجهزه الامن انه عمليه ده
س وبحسب المصادر فقد قتلت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه منفذه عمليه الدهس بعد تراجله
من السياره مؤكده ان الحادثه كان متعمدا
ومخططا له
حركه حماس اعلنت مسؤوليتها عن العمليه
وقالت ان منفذه عمليه الدهس في تل ابيب هو
احد عناصرها واوضحت في بيان لها ان منفذ
العمليه يدعى عبد الوهاب عيسى خلايلي
ويبلغ من العمر 20 عاما من بلده السموع في
الخليل وقالت حماس ان العمليه تاتي ردا
اوليا على العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
في جنين
ينضم الي من القدس الان لمزيد من المتابعه
حول هذا الموضوع مدير مكتب العربيه في
فلسطين زياد حلب زياد اهلا وسهلا بك اخر
حصيله لعمليه الدهس بدايه وكيف سترد
اسرائيل يا ترى زياد غير ما تقوم به من
هذا الهجوم الواسع النطاق على مخيم جنين
طبعا الحصيله لم تتغير كثيرا طالب هناك
ثمانيه مصابين من بينهم اثنان في حال
الخطر العمليه تصنف بانها فرديه بمعنى
فلسطيني من الخليل قام بها عمليا في شمالي
تل ابيب وكانت مت
وقعه تكن
اي معلومات استخباراتيه بشانها وهذه طبيعه
العمليات الفرديه عندما يقوم شخص وحيدا
بتنفيذ عمليات لا يشارك احد عمليا لا
تنتقل للمعلومات الاستخباراتيه
للاسرائيليين السؤال الان كيف سيؤثر ذلك
على الهجوم الاسرائيلي الحالي على مخيم
جنين بمعنى هل يستطيع ان نتنياهو سحب
القوات الاسرائيليه في خلال ساعات بعد هذا
المشهد بين المزدوجين المحرج في تل ابيب
في العمق الاسرائيلي ام لا ان ذلك سيطيل
الابد هذه العمليه ولكن قليله التحضيرات
في اسرائيل لان عمليه جنين او الهجوم على
جنين من يطول كثيرا في
الاعلام الاسرائيلي يعني ان كان هناك
اجماع
لهذا
الهجومين سياسيا واعلاميا الان بدات
الاسئله كيف ان الف جندي اسرائيلي وعشرات
اليات تقتحم مخيما كجنين نصف كيلو متر
مربع يعيش فيه
فلسطيني عمليا ولا انجازات بالنسبه للجيش
الاسرائيلي ولهذا يتحدثون الان في اسرائيل
طالب على
تدمير البنيه التحتيه هو الهدف وليس
اغتيال
المسلحين او المقاتلين في زياد هل من
الممكن ان توسع اسرائيل دائره قصفها لتطال
غزه لانه من المفارقات يعني او من المرات
القليله التي تتبنى حركه حماس صراحه عمليه
الدهش في تل ابيب وتقول ان من نفذ العمليه
هو احد عناصرها هل نتوقع ردا من تل ابيب
على قطاع غزه ام لا يعني ربما في هذا
الوقت اسرائيل ستكتفي بما يجري في جنين
اسرائيل اساس ثقفت انجاز التعبير عمليه
جنينه والهجوم على مخيم جنين بامد زمنيه
قصير لانها لا تريد مواجهه مفتوحه مع قطاع
غزه الصواريخ او اطلاق صواريخ من جنوب
لبنان على الجبهة الشماليه تجاه اسرائيل
تريد ان تتجنب ذلك والجيش الاسرائيلي يريد
ان يتجنب اتساع رقعه المواجهه ولهذا
الامال ضعيف وان كان واردا لان هناك ضغوط
لان هناك ضغوطا من بين جبير وسمودج طوال
الوقت على نتنياهو بان يكون مبادرا وان
يغير المعادلات بمعنى يرد في غزه على ما
يحدث في الضفه الغربيه المحتله والعكس
صحيح لكن حاليا الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يبدو
متحمسا للدخول في مواجهه
من القدس مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين
زياد حلبي دائما شكرا جزيلا لك زياد على
كل هذه المتابعه
هذا وعبر مكتب الامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه عن قلقه من حجم العمليات الجويه
والبريه التي تجري في جنين بالضفه الغربيه
واكد انزعاجه بشده بعد مقتل ثلاثه اطفال
فلسطينيين في جنين خلال العمليات
الاسرائيليه ومن جهته اكد المتحدث باسم
منظمه الصحه العالميه ان فرق طبيه منعت من
الدخول لاسعاف المصابين جراء الهجمات على
جنين بما في ذلك الوصول الى الاشخاص الذين
اصيبوا بجروح خطيره
المتحدث باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه قال ان
المستجبين الاوائل لنداء الاغاثه منعوا من
دخول مخيم جنين للاجئين بما في ذلك الوصول
الى الاشخاص الذين اصيبوا بجروح خطره في
اشاره الى القيود التي فرضتها القوات
الاسرائيليه على المنطقه
تم منعه سيارات الاسعاف والمستجيبين
الاوائل من دخول اجزاء من مخيم جنين
للاجئين ومساعده الاشخاص الذين اصيبوا
بجروح خطيره لا يوجد حاليا ممر امن لوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه وهو محور تركيز رئيسي
لمفاوضات الامم المتحده الجاريه وقد شاركت
وزاره الصحه قائمه بالامدادات الطبيه التي
هي في امس الحاجه اليها والتي تقوم منظمه
الصحه العالميه والشركاء الصحيون
بمراجعتها
اذهب الى جنين مجددا ينضم الي عبر الهاتف
الدكتور وسام بكر وهو مدير مستشفى جنين
الحكومي دكتور وسام اهلا وسهلا بك الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه بدايه اخر حصيله
لعدد الضحايا والجرحى وهل ما زالت اسرائيل
تمنع طواقم الاسعاف والدفاع المدني من
الوصول الى المصابين في المخيم
يعني في اخر حصيره عدد الشهداء هو عصر
شهداء منذ بدء الاجتياح الاسرائيلي لمدينه
ومخيم جنين من ناحيه عدد الجرحى تجاوز
المئه تحت وزعه على معظم مستشفيات المدينه
شاهد خلال هذا النهار يعني هناك عدد اقل
من الجرحى مقارنه
بالبارحه ما زالت اصوات الاشتباكات واصوات
الانفجارات مسموعه بالقرب من المخيم
وقريبنا من المستشفى طيب هل ما زالت
القوات الاسرائيليه تمنع طواقم الاسعاف
والدفاع المدني الفلسطيني من الوصول الى
المصابين في المخيم لانه في كتير كلام عن
هذا الموضوع
هذا صحيح يعني طواقم الهلال الاحمر
والاسعافات تمنع من الدخول الى
المخيم ويتم اطلاق النار عليها بشكل
تحذيره لمنع اقترابها من المناطق التي
تحتوي على مصابين مما يضطر الاسعاف
والمساكين الى سلوك الاخرى وتعرضهم لخطر
شديد محاولين انقاذ ما يستطيع انقاذه من
الجرحى
طيب دكتور وسام ابرز الاحتياجات التي
تريدونها بشكل عاجل في المستشفى وهل
المستشفى مهيا لهذا العدد من الضحايا
من ناحيه الاحتياجات والمستهلكات
والمستلزمات طبيه يعني احنا كنا ماخذين
احتياطاتنا خلال الفتره الماضيه بسبب وجود
تهديدات الاسرائيليه لاسته فكانت
استعداداتنا
بتخزين مستهلكات طبيه تكفي فتره من الزمن
لمواجهه اي احتلال وايضا اليوم وصلتنا
مساعدات من وزاره الصحه ومن دبليو اتش او
من مؤسسه باما
لدعم المستشفى بمزيد من المستهلكات
والمستلزمات التي تشجع على الصمود
واستمرار بتقديم الخدمات الطبيه لكن يعني
طول فتره الحصار وطول فتره الاشتباكات
تؤثر سلبا على القطاع الصحي بالمستشفى
بشكل عام من حيث ان الخدمه الطبيه
يعني انخفضت بشكل كبير لباقي الفئات من
المرضى هناك حالات ولاده وهناك حالات
عمليات
هنالك قسم اطفال هناك مرضى مشكله معظم
هؤلاء المرضى لم يتلقوا الخدمات خلال
اليومين بسبب صعوبه الوصول الى المستشفى
لانها ضمن دائره الاشتباكات
القوات الاسرائيليه يعني بمعدل كل ساعات
تقترب من المستشفى وتطلق
قنابل الغاز يعني قبل قليل شاهدنا قسم
الطوارئ لم يستطع الموظفين والاطباء
والكافر الطبي والتمريضي والاداري من
البقاء فيه وعدل المواطنين كلهم غادروا
القسم بسبب دخول الغازات المثيره للدموع
اليه حقيقه يعني الوضع الصحي ليس فقط على
استقبال الجرحى يعني هنالك صعوبه لكن
لاستمرار تقديم الخدمه لباقي الفئات
دكتور وسام تعرف اسرائيل دائما تقول انها
لا تستهدف المدنيين وانها فقط تستهدف
المقاتلين الفصائل انت خلال متابعتك يعني
الضحايا الذين سواء من من جرحى او قتلى
ما هي نسبه المدنيين بين بين هؤلاء
والاصابات في اي مكان من الجسد تكون
نسبه المدنيين هي نسبه هي النسبه الاعلى
من بين الاصابات
وكانت الاصابات معظمها من
[موسيقى]
ناتجه عن اطلاق الصواريخ يعني كانت
الساعات الاولى من بدل السياح كان
الاعتماد عاملا
لاستخدام الصواريخ من الطائرات المسيره
اليوم خلال زياره بعض المرضى كان احد
المصابين هو ضابط في الدفاع المدني كان
موجود في المخيم وتعرضه للقصر التاريخي
وهو مرتدي بزته بجانب الهلال ضباط الهلال
الاحمر بعد تعرض المخيم للقصر كان الدفاع
المدني والهلال الاحمر المتواجد اسعاف
المرضى تعرضوا لقصف وهو موجود الان في
المستشفى وقمنا بزيارته مع الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي عندما قام لزياره بعض المرضى في
المستشفى فهنالك يعني مدنيين ومن الناس
المهتمين يعني المعنيين بالعمل
الميداني الانساني اللي هم الدفاع المدني
والهلال الاحمر تعرضه للاصابه خلال هذا
الادوار ساكتفي بهذا القدر من جنين
الدكتور وسام بكر مدير مستشفى جنين
الحكومي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين امام
قمه شنغهاي للتعاون ان بلاده تواجه محاوله
لتشكيل دوله منوئه على الحدود وانها لن
تسمح بذلك مؤكدا ان روسيا ملتزمه بتشكيل
نظام عالمي قائم على القانون الدولي كما
واشار الى ان الدوله تواجه حربا هجينه
وعقوبات غير مسبوقه
وتقاوم بثقه الضغوط الغربيه بفضل وحده
الجبهه الداخليه مضيفا ان 80% من
التبادلات التجاريه مع الصين تتم عبر
العملات المحليه
وان روسيا ستوسع هذا التعاون مع دول اخرى
وبعد شهر من الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد نقلت
شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه عن خبراء ان
التقدم بطيء ولم يلبي التوقعات
ونقلت الشبكه الامريكيه في تقريرها عن
جندي اوكراني مشارك في هجوم ان حقول
الالغام في جنوب اوكرانيا كثيفه للغايه
ولا يمكن للقوات التي تحاول تحرير المنطقه
الا ان تتقدم شجره بشجره وقال الجندي ايضا
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تواجه دفاعات شديده
التحصين وهجمات جويه فيما يبدو انهم
يتحركون ببطء الى حد كبير في المقابل
حلفاء اوكرانيا الغربيون قلقون من حقيقه
ان تقدم هجوم المضاد الذي طال انتظاره
يقاس بالامتار وليس بالكيلومترات
هذا واعترف مسؤولون اوكرانيون وغربيون ان
الهجوم المضاد فشل حتى الان في تحقيق تقدم
كبير
ووفقا لتقييم اجراه معهد دراسه الحرب
للابحاث ومقره في واشنطن فان بعض الاقسام
الاكثر استراتيجيه في الخط الامامي تحرسها
خطوط دفاع روسيه متعدده ما يجعل من الصعب
جدا على الاوكرانيين اختراقها
من باريس ينضم الي لمزيد من المتابعه حول
هذا الموضوع الباحث السياسي الدكتور محمد
سيف الدين ومن كييف ينضم الي ايضا
الدبلوماسي السابق والمستشار لحاكم خرسون
فولدمير شوماكو دكتور سيف الدين من باريس
ابدا معك برايك ما هي العوامل التي ساهمت
في بطء او تعثر الهجوم الاوكراني المضام
وهل بات لزاما على كييف الان ان تفكر
بتكتيكات اخرى
نعم بدايه
العوامل متعدده بعضها مرتبط بسياق المعارك
في الاشهر الماضيه خسرت كياف كثيرا من
يعني على المستوى البشري وعلى المستوى
العتاد في الاشهر الماضيه وخاضت معارك
شرسه جدا في مخموت وفي مدن اخرى وبالتالي
قدرتها والزخم الذي كان مطلوبا للهجوم
المضاد تاثر بشكل واضح وبشكل ملموس
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك التجهيزات الروسيه
والتحضير وبناء خطوط الدفاعات ومن المعلوم
الان ان وفق المعطيات المتوفره بان هناك
ثلاث خطوط اساسيه ثلاثه خطوط اساسيه
للدفاع من الالغام ومن التحصينات التي
بنتها روسيا على مدى اشهر بالاضافه الى
ذلك هناك تشكيلات هناك تفوق روسي واضح جدا
على مستوى القوات الجويه وهناك ايضا
الغارات التي تشنها روسيا بالطائرات
المسيره جيران ولانست وطائرات اخرى وهذه
اثبتت فاعليه عاليه جدا خلال المواجهات
السابقه بالاضافه الى كل ذلك وب هناك ايضا
الضربات بصواريخ البعيده هذا على مستوى
المعارك الميدانيه ومستوى بالاضافه الى
ذلك هناك نعم دكتور سيف الدين لانتقل الى
السيد شوماكوف ساعود اليك
هذا البطء وهذا التعثر الاوكراني في
الهجوم المضاد الى عماده سيؤثر على الدعم
الغربي لكييف بمعنى انه ما في دعم هيك لا
متناهي هذا الدعم يجب ان يقترن بتقدم
اوكرانيا وطالما ما في تقدم يمكن لهذا
الدعم ان يتوقف ما رايك
نرى السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته تحيه
طيبه
بصراحه لا يوجد جدول حول هجوم مضاد لنتذكر
لما غرب كان متراجرا وخاصه حول تقديم
لاوكرانيا مواعظات عسكريه مختلفه نحن
نتذكر هذا حوار طويل حول تقديم لاوكرانيا
دبابات من طراس
والاخوه في نفس الوقت هي لم يضعوا لوقت
وهي شيدت خطوط دفاعيه مختلفه في جنوب
اوكرانيا
روسيا حشدت عدد كبير من القواتها في
جنوب اوكرانيا اكثر من 120 الف جنديا كمان
هي حاسده عدد كبير من القوات
منية نعم وخمسون الف جنديا اندونيسيا انا
بصفه عامه موافق مع ضيف كريما بان في تفوق
روسي في في قوات الجويه وكمان صواريخ
لنتذكر امريكا رفضت لاوكرانيا تقديم
لمقاتلات من طراس اف 16 دبابات وهذا اكيد
الجوس لا يتجازى منه لتنفيزه هجوم مضاد
ناجح على معروف عدد الضخم من الالغام التي
روسيا الزعره في خطوط التماس ونحن الان في
حاجه ماسه الى اجهزه وماكينات لازاله كل
هذه الالغام ولكن على الرغم من الالغام
موجود هجوم مضاد قوات مصالحه اوكرانيه
خاصه في محافظه
التساؤل الى الدكتور سيف الدين دكتور سيف
الدين هل تعتقد انه يعني ما في تشك على
بياض ربما وانه الدعم الغربي تحديدا
الامريكي ليكيا في هذا الهجوم المضاد ربما
مرتبط بتحقيق تقدم طالما هذا التقدم لم
يتحقق هل تعتقد ان هذا سيؤثر على دفعات
المساعدات العسكريه الى كيف انه لا ما في
شيء يعني انا مش مش متناهي المساله ام لا
نعم سيدي العزيز
المساعدات والدعم العسكري كله مرهون
بالتوقيت بشكل اساسي ومرهون بالصوره
العامه للمواجهه نحن لا نتحدث فقط عن
المواجهه العسكريه وما يجري على الارض
طبعا من المطلوب من اكياب من قبل الحلفاء
الغربيين بان يعني تصل الى نتائج سريعه
والنتائج تكون فاعله تجبر روسيا على جلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات وتقديم تنازلات على
هذه الطاوله في وقت لاحق ما يجري الان على
الارض لا يناسب هذا التوقع بالاضافه الى
ذلك ايضا هناك مشكله جدا
لو سمحت لي هذا التعثر الاوكراني الم يجبر
الغرب على الضغط على اكياس
للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات ولو بالشروط
الروسيه
نعم بالضبط هذا ما اشير اليه بالتحديد انا
اتحدث ما كان مطلوبا من كيف قبل هذه
النتائج التي نشهدها اليوم كان مطلوبا
اجبار روسيا على جلوس الى طاوه المفاوضات
الان في شهر حزيران يونيو الماضي كشفت
واشنطن بوست عن الزياره التي قام بها رئيس
الاستخبارات الامريكيه الى كيف وعن فحوى
هذه الزياره ومضامين المباحثات مع الجهات
الاوكرانيه والتي بحسب الصحيفه والتي
اكدتها تصريحات اخرى بانهم ضغطوا على كيف
في هذا السياق وقالوا ان الهجوم يتحرك
بشكل بطيء جدا وان هذا يعني يجب ان تصل
الى حدود وتلقوا وعود بالمناسبه حسب
الصحيفه بان كيف سوف تصل الى حدود شبه
جزيره القرم وبالتالي هناك يمكن ان تبدا
المفاوضات هذا الامر في الميدان لا يبدو
واقعيا حتى هذه اللحظه وهناك نعم وهناك
معطيات تشير الى يعني الى عكس ذلك
طيب لان قل هذا التساؤل ايضا مجددا للسيد
شو ماكو سيد شوماكو هذا التعثر لا سيحمل
الغرب مش على
زياده امدادات السلاح ولا اف 16 ولا غيرها
هذا لا سيجبر الغرب على اعاده مقاربه
المساله اي الضغط على الجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات مع الروس وان كان بالشروط
الروسيه ما رايك
بصفه عامه انا موافق معكم نعم من الممكن
في مستقبل سوف يكون الضغط على اوكرانيا
حول مفاوضات مع روسيا ولكن سؤال مطروح
حالتها ولا هل الروسيا هي سوف تكون موافقه
على مفاوضات مع اوكرانيا لان كمان نحن
نشاهد في الصالح وروسيا الان هذا كمان
استنزاف اوكرانيا وايضا استنزاف غرب
بالمناسبه في صالح الصين ثمانيه استنزاف
غرق هنا في اوكرانيا يعني سؤال مطروح على
طاوله هل روسيا سوف تطلب مفاوضات اوكرانيا
اكيد لم تكون الموافقه لاي مفاوضات
نحن كمان ندركه هنا في اوكرانيا بان الوقت
ليس في صالح اوكرانيا وخاصه الانتخابات في
امريكا في سنه جايه اوكرانيا عنده
اوكرانيا تقريبا سنه واحده لتحرير
الاغلبيه من الاراضي المطلوبه كان الواحد
ان نحن ندرك من الممكن اوكرانيا تحت صوت
تحتاج عند
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
ماكرون يعلن حال الطوارئ وذلك لتشريع
اعمار البلديات المتضرره جراء عمليات
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه تجددت الاشتباكات العنيفه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مدن
الخرطوم الثلاث ام درمان الخرطوم وخرطوم
بحري حيث افاد مراسل العربيه في السودان
بسماع دوي انفجارات واشتباكات اتجاه معسكر
قوات الاحتياط المركزي والمنطقه الصناعيه
والسوق الشعبي بام درمان وشمال وغرب الحاج
يوسف بضاحيه شرق النيل التابعه لمحله
الخرطوم بحري
وشهدت مناطق جنوب الخرطوم مواجهات
بالاسلحه الثقيله مع تحليق مكثف للطيران
وسماع اصوات المضادات الارضيه
نشر سلاح المدرعات السوداني في ام درمان
مقطعا مصورا قال فيه انه كبد قوات الدعم
السريع خسائر فادحه والسيطره على خمسين
عربه تابعه للدعم السريع
الله اكبر الله اكبر فازله في سلاح
المدرعات
تدمر قوات العدو في موقع الري المصري ودمر
العالم موقع الريال المصري وتستلم 50
عربيه واثنين مدرعه
قوات المدرعات سلاح المدرعات الباسله تدمر
قوات العدو في الريال المصري وتستلم 50
عربيه لاندكروزر بكامل عتاده وتسليحه
وتستلم اثنين مدرعه
ومع استمرار الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه افاد الناطق
الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه بانه تم توجيه
قيادات الفرق والمناطق العسكريه باستقبال
وتجهيز المقاتلين المتطوعين وان عليهم
التوجه لاقرب قياده او وحده عسكريه حسب
قوله ياتي ذلك بعد حث القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
المدنيين الى الانضمام الى القوات
العسكريه في القتال ضد الدعم السريع ومن
غير الواضح ما اذا كانت دعوه الجيش
السوداني للمتطوعين هي بمثابه تجنيد
اجباري
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الان في محيط الاذاعه الان في محيط
الاذاعه الانذاعه
محيط الاذاعه
معي من القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع اللواء بابكر ابراهيم احمد وهو
الخبير العسكري واللواء السابق في القوات
الجويه السودانيه لواء بكر كيف يجب فهم
هذا النداء من قبل الجيش السوداني وهل هو
بمثابه تجديد اجباري ام لا يعني يترك
للافراد للمدنيين حريه الاختيار
السلام عليكم وللمشاهدين لك اولا ليس
المقصود هي القوات المدنيه انما المقصود
هي قوات الاحتياط والمعروف ان قوات
الاحتياط تخضع للقائد العام ومن حقه ان
يستدعيها متى وراى ذلك مناسبا كان هنالك
اختلاف في الرائب بين قوات الاحتياط
والغائده العام قوات الاحتياط كانت ترى
انها يجب ان تشارك في القتال منذ اول يوم
لكن القوات المسلحه رات ان تستدعيها في
هذا الوقت
قوات الاحتياط تمثل معيشي القوات المسلحه
القوات النظاميه الاخرى اضافه لقوات
الدفاع الشعبي وقوات المجاهدين وقوات
الطلب
من من قوات الدفاع الشعبي بس لواء بابكر
ما هو السؤال ما هو ما رد السؤال شو
الاسباب لطالما قال الجيش في بياناته انه
يسيطر على زمام الامور ان يفسح المجال ان
يستدعي الاحتياط هل هذا يعني انه يعاني
نقصا في عديده وهو يحتاج الى رفض قواته
بعديد من اجل المعركه المقبله ام ماذا
ابدا اذا كان يحتاج كان استدعاها منذ اول
ايام الحرب لكن
القوات
الان واجبها حسب
حسب ما نرى من اعاده التموضع للجيش ان
واجبها هي
التامين المناطق التي تم تنشيطها لذلك هي
قد شاركت في المرحله الاخيره من عمليات
التمشيط
واخراج القوات التي
كانت تحتل المنازل الان
القوات الشعب المسلحه تقول انها
على وشك تحرير منطقه الخرطوم بعد منطقه ام
درمان خلال 24 ساعه القادمه هذا يعني ان
القوات المسلحه تحتاج لاعاده موضع وتذهب
الى منطقه بحري
منطقه ام درمان تحتاج لتامين لذلك سوف توك
ل لقوات الاحتياط تامين هذه المنطقه
بالتزامم مع قوات الشرطيه
لافساح المجال للقوات
لواء بكر لا اع ايه اعود الى صلب المساله
سيقول لك قائل لو كان الجيش ممسكا تماما
بزمام الامور كما يقول في بياناته فلماذا
الضروره الى استدعاء الاحتياط
انت تعلم ان القوات القوات الدعم السريع
كانت قوات داخل منطقه الخرطوم وهي مدافعه
عن الاماكن التي تحتلها ما قبل الحرب
وقوات الجيش هي قوات مهاجمه لاخراج هذه
القوات المدافعه والمعروف ان نسبه القوات
المهاجمه لقوات للقوات المدافعه نسبه واحد
الى ثلاثه فاذا كان القوات الدعم السريع
80 الف
الجيش يحتاج الى 240 الف لاخراجهم لكن انا
على ما اعلم ان الجيش قد قاتلهم بنفس
عددهم ب 80 الف ولكن الان يريد ان ينتقل
من منطقه لمنطقه ويريد ان يؤمن هذه
المنطقه منطقه ام درمان التي تم تحريرها
لذلك استعانه بهواه الاحتياط من القاهره
اللواء بابكر ابراهيم احمد الخبير العسكري
واللواء السابق في القوات الجويه
السودانيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
اعلن رئيس الفرنسي مكروح حال الطوارئ
لتشريعي عمليات اعاده الاعمار في البلديات
المتضرره جراء اعمال الشغب على خلفيه
المقتل المراهق نائل المرزوق على يد
الشرطه الفرنسي وابدا مكروه حذرا شديدا
حيال العوده الى الهدوء بعدما شهدت فرنسا
سبعه ليال متتاليه من اعمال الشغب او قاعه
اضرارا كبيره وخلال اجتماع مع رؤساء
البلديات اعتبر ماكرون ان ذروه هذه
الاعمال قد مررت
من داخل قصر الاليزيه ينضم اليه مدير مكتب
العربيه في فرنسا حسين فياض قنيبر حسين
اهلا وسهلا بك كيف يفهم اعلان الرئيس
مكروه حال الطوارئ واقرانها باعاده اعمار
ما تم تخريبه
جراء عمليات الشغب يعني اقران اعلان حاله
طوارئ فقط بهذه المساله
نعم في الواقع الرئيس الفرنسي الذي استقبل
طالب حوالي 220 من رؤساء البلديات عبر
فرنسا ممن تعرضوا لتهديدات واعمال العنف
من بينهم تسعه وتسعون رئيس بلديه تعرضوا
لهجمات مباشره بدا هؤلاء يخرجون تباعا بعد
ساعات من اللقاء الذي استمر بينهم وبين
الرئيس الفرنسي اما اعلن عن اعاده اعمار
المناطق التي تعرضت للتخريب يهدف الى
تهدئه خواطر سكان هذه المناطق الذين
يشعرون بانهم تركوا لمجموعات من مثيري
الشغب الراي العام الفرنسي يستغرب عدم
قدره قوى الشرطه التي بلغ عديدها حوالي 45
الف شرطي ودركي عدم قدرتها على ضبط الامور
الا بعد مرور ايام وطبعا الزياره النادره
التي قام بها الرئيس ماكرونلي مواقع
الشرطه الليله الماضيه تخللها حوار بينه
وبين وضباط وعناصر من الشرطه قال له احدهم
ان اخطر ما يحصل في فرنسا اليوم اننا نحن
عناصر الشرطه لم نعد نخيف مثيري الشغب
الرئيس الفرنسي يسعى الى الشروع في حوار
مع القوى السياسيه والبرلمانيه ومع
السلطات المحليه في كل مدينه من اجل فهم
افضل واعمق لما حصل مؤخرا من اجل تجنبه في
المستقبل كما قال مصدر حكومي فرنسي حسين
هل الرئيس مكروه قال انه ذروه الاحداث قد
مرت بمعنى يعني كانه يقول انه الاسوا قد
مر هل فعلا وفق متابعتك الامور تنحو الى
التهدئه ام لا يعني ان النيران ما زالت
تحت الرماد وبشكل كبير
طرحنا السؤال على بعض رؤساء البلديات
الذين خرجوا من الالزاف في هذه الباحه
الواقعه خلفي قال لنا بعضهم يجب ان نحذر
المبالغه في التفاؤل مذكرين بانه في اليوم
الثالث من ازمه الضواحي التي استمرت ثلاثه
اسابيع عام 2005 في ولايه الثانيه للرئيس
شراك عادت الامور والتهابت مجددا واستمرت
بعد هدوء عابر لفتره اسبوعين على الاقل من
هنا يقول هؤلاء انه يجب انتظار ما سيحصل
ليله العيد الوطني الفرنسي في الرابع عشر
من تموز كتورجيه كما يعرف هنا ليحكم على
الامور بالمناسبه رؤساء البلديات الذين
التقوا الرئيس ماكرون هنا في الاليزا طالب
انقسموا بين رؤساء بلديات يساريين
الطالبوا بتعزيز الاختلاط بين مختلف
الانتماءات والاعراق في ضواحي المدن
الفرنسيه وتعزيز الحوار بين هذه الجهات
وتعزيز البنى التحتيه من مستشفيات
المرتبات وتعزيز عدد الاطباء وتعزيز وسائل
النقل العام والرؤساء البلديات اليمنيون
الذين دعوا الى تعزيز قبضه الشرطه
وتمكينها من القضاء على مثير الشغب وسجنهم
جميعا بالمناسبه الرئيس ماكرون كان حذر من
ان اي فتى يقوم باثاره الشغب فان اهله
يدويه سيتعرضون لعقوبات ماليه بمعنى ان
المساعدات الاجتماعيه الفرنسيه ستقطع عن
ذوي اي فتى يساهم من الان فصاعدا في عمليه
حسين لو سمحتم انت عندما عندما تجول في
الشوارع الفرنسيه هل بدات الشوارع المحال
يعني تلملم نفسها ان صح التعبير ام لا
الكل يتريث ما ستحمله الايام المقبله وهل
تمت يعني في تحضيرات
لمواجهات ما في الساعات المقبله ام لا هذا
كله انتهى
لا مؤشرات على التحضير لمواجهات في الايام
المقبله لكن لا يستبعد ان تعود المواجهات
عند حصول ادنى حادث يمكننا القول طالب ان
هذه الايام الخمسه كانت الاصعب في فرنسا
منذ عام 2005 يكفي ان اشير الى انه جرى
خلالها توقيف ثلاثه الاف وثلاثمائه واربعه
وخمسين شخصا خلال ايام خمسه فقط وهذا
العدد يوازي ما تم توقيفه خلال ثلاثه
اسابيع من ازمه الضواحي عام 2005 عشرات
المحال التجاريه بالمئات المحال التجاريه
اتعرضت لاضرار بلغ عدد المحال التجاريه
التي تعرضت لاضرار حوالي 1100 اشعلت الاف
الحرائق وتضررت مئات المباني العامه
والخاصه وجرح المئات من عناصر الشرطه كل
من باريس وبوردو وليل ومارسيليا وتولوز
وايضا في ديجون وميلوز وغيرها الفرنسيه
بهذا القدر من داخل قصر الاليزيه مدير
مكتب العربيه في فرنسا حسين فياض قنيبر
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين على كل هذه المتابعه
يشكو الصيادون في قريه اللوزه التونسيه
قله الحيله ففي رحله صيدهم لكسب رزقهم
يواجهون ما لم يكن في الحسبان يرمون
شباكهم في سواحل صفاقس لكنهم حين يسحبونها
يتفاجئون بالماساه التي التقطتها شباك
صيدهم
اشلاء مهاجرين وليس سمكا يعودون به
[موسيقى]
تم خروج سفنهم عباب البحر الابيض المتوسط
ينتظرون على مضض ما عادت شباك صياد صفاقس
التونسيه تلتقط اسماكا وانما بصمه رحيل
ماساويه عنوانها هجره غير مشروعه
يعني امور ثقه الخيال تتكدس هذه الزوارق
الرثه على سواحل قريه اللوزه عتيقه
ومتهالكه لا جلد لها على حمل نفسها واذا
بها تباع بمبالغ عاليه لتبحر بالمهمومين
الفرين من اعباء بلدانهم يفتش الصيادون عن
رزقهم
يرمون شباكا لا تكاد تصطاد في الاونه
الاخيره سوى اشلاء مهاجرين
رام الجثث انا انا عندي شكون
يخدم فهمته في الشباك يطلع ساعات تطفو
جثثهم بعد ان عامت وارتحلت لكن المتوسط
انقلب عليهم وكتبت لرحله هجرتهم النهايه
انكبت اجسادهم من على متن سفن صديقه احترا
قوامها فلا هي عبرت بهم مسافه 120 كيلو
مترا واوصلتهم الى جزيره لامبي دوسي
الايطاليه ولا تركتهم يترقبون مصيرا عدا
المرور بالبحر الذي بات يرى ضريح موت غائر
ترحال مرير ترتكبه هذه القوارب او ربما
اللاهثون ضمن منظمات التهريب ليغروا بمن
تقطعت بهم السبل انا مش نعبيها
منظمات لخادعين بامل الوصول الى بر الامان
او مخدوعين بان تصبح هذه القوارب مصدر
عيشهم لكنهم تغافلوا عن خطوره خوض غمار
رحله صنف طريقها بالاكثر دمويه في العالم
اسراء الصغير العربيه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
سويسرا تعيد قطعه من تمثال لرمسيس الثاني
الى مصر
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اعاد تسويسرا الى مصر قطعه من
تمثال للفرعون رمسيس الثاني تعود الى
3400 عام خلت كانت قد سرقت قبل عقود من
معبد في ابيدوس وبحسب المكتب الفيدرالي
للثقافه فان القطعه التي اعيدت الى مصر
كانت مسروقه من معبد رمسيس الثاني بين
نهايه الثمانينات القرن الفائت ومطلع
تسعينياته
ويشكل تمثال الفرعون رمسيس الثاني الذي
تعود هذه القطعه اليه جزءا من تمثال جماعي
يظهر الملك جالسا الى جانب عدد من الالهه
المصريه
نشره الخامسه المفصله وفينكم بها من
العربيه اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
وبركاته المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات